Đóng tình với cái việc là, bây giờ, cái cái mục tiêu là đảy nền trên đỏ rồi,
đánh cao hiểu, bà xử rục đồng bốt.
Đói công chì.
Chính nhưng mà nó phải là cập nhanh hẳng với lại, cái gì?
Chứ rồi là bên đẻ là xin kênh là là cao rồi người ra, chế à nhỏ, anh ơi,
bệnh mà các thứ tất cả chế tạm trang, thì cái đỏ là gì?
Điều mà cứu đẻ là không phải là chỉ là một dường bao nhiêu tiền mà bên đẻ là của địa của trong cái nhóm.
Còn ra đình của người ta bà cái nhóm, người này như trên nào.
Hãy thì hai như là khi mà người dân đã phải, tôi tôi xin kẹp thêm của chúng.
khi người dân đã phải là gì?
Hình xin, người ta phải, gì ở bây giờ, gì dây, gì dồi?
Nó là gì? Nó là một cái sự đi xin chúng ta phải không nhạc?
Và là một cái sự đông góp đứng lào của người dân, tôi phải là cái sinh đẹp pạc chiến đất nước.
Chứ bây giờ chúng ta cũng xin với, cái chuyện mà chúng ta đẹp tu hồi như thế này mà chúng ta lấy không tính, cái chuyện là người ta phải.
Sống như ra làm sao thì làm sao mà, đẹp sinh với là cái sinh đất,
người ta phải tư bỏ, cái người dùng gà của tư bỏ, cái gì?
Nó là một người ta phải là một người ta, nhưng mà, đất tận lại trong cuộc tạm làm ăn cuộc người ta.
Tại mà, sinh kế cuộc người ta đẹp mà, vực vụ cho sự phát triển của đất nước vụ là 1 chung của cậu đồng.
Mà nếu như mà này chúng ta lấy, vì tu hồi mà không tính, cái chuyện tại lịnh tuyệt,
thì tuyệt cho rằng là, đúng không có giả rời sạch.
Chè chè chè nó sẽ ra là nếu như tuy tạp quy định, tôi thì tôi cũng,
và vì cái người ăn này nhưng mà chúng tôi nghĩ là phần phải vính đến cái chuyện là,
để làm sao mà chánh là, cái chân hợp quy định là phải vỏ,
để chánh cái chân hợp ngoài lại, không trở thành phố biểu.
Thì đó họ sẽ là cái chuyện của biểu chính, chính không phải là,
bất đại cho nên là cái này là cả tôi đã nghĩ là,
2 cái độ dân này không phải được xam chạp,
được cái tự tự ướng và đình hấp hạp, được tự kiện.